[Music]
if your business model depends on paying
your workers starvation wages
you should not be in business
the federal minimum wage of seven
dollars 25 cents an hour hasn't been
raised since 2009
that's the longest period without an
increase since the minimum wage was
enacted
meaning today's minimum wage is actually
worth far less than it was in 2009 this
is an insult to american workers and bad
for our economy it's far past time to
raise the minimum wage to at least 15 an
hour
today's federal minimum wage is a
starvation wage a full-time minimum wage
worker can't afford a two-bedroom rental
in any city county or state in the
entire country meanwhile billionaires
like jeff bezos can afford a dc mansion
with 25 bathrooms and five living rooms
just one of his many matches
now the current minimum wage isn't so
low because these workers are worth less
than they were years ago quite the
country if the minimum wage had kept
pace with workers productivity increases
since 1968
it would be over twenty two dollars an
hour today
even so conservatives are out to scare
you about raising the wage
let's debunk each of their talking
points
myth number one
if businesses have to raise wages
they'll cut employees hours or cut jobs
altogether
rubbish
since at least the 1930s critics have
argued that setting any minimum standard
of decency at the workplace will raise
employer costs and kill jobs child labor
laws the 40-hour work week workplace
safety laws if we've learned anything
over the years it's that treating
workers decently is worth the price
besides an abundance of research shows
that increases in the minimum wage do
not reduce the overall number of jobs
researchers examined 138 state-level
minimum wage increases and found that
the number of low-wage jobs remained
essentially unchanged in the five years
following the increase but workers were
paid more
that's a job upgrade not a job loss
and multiple studies have come to the
same conclusion when i led the fight to
raise the minimum wage in 1996
many conservatives predicted huge job
losses well i'm happy to report that
after the increase almost 10 million
low-wage workers received a raise with
no decline in overall employment it's
simply a myth that raising the wage
automatically means lost jobs not to
mention the benefits for workers
themselves raising the wage to 15 an
hour by 2025 as proposed in the raise
the wage act would give 32 million
workers a raise here's the bottom line
if your business model depends on paying
your workers starvation wages
you should not be in business myth
number two
small businesses won't be able to afford
a higher wage and will be put out of
business
baloney
the fact is a higher minimum wage can
actually lower costs to small businesses
how
well for starters a higher minimum wage
attracts more potential workers into the
labor force thereby giving employers
more choice of whom to hire this leads
to higher productivity and better
service better service means more
satisfied clients and customers higher
paid workers are also more likely to
stick around saving businesses the hefty
costs that come with recruiting hiring
and training new workers a study of the
san francisco airport confirms this
researchers found that following a wage
increase a majority of workers who
received a raise improved their overall
performance the higher wages even led to
shorter airport lines
researchers also found that employee
turnover declined by 34
saving an estimated 6.6 million dollars
a year smart business owners understand
this henry ford after introducing the
five dollar day in 1914 when typical
industry wages were less than half that
called it his best cost cutting strategy
because the productivity boost that
followed
myth number three if the minimum wage is
raised prices for everything will
skyrocket and lead to widespread
inflation
wrong again
researchers have found that for every 10
increase in the minimum wage prices
increased by less than half a percent
and it's a temporary price increase
occurring only in the month the wage
hike goes into effect no way this sparks
inflation in fact the minimum wage needs
to be raised so it can keep up with
inflation because of inflation today's
minimum wage is worth almost a third
less than it was worth in 1968
and since it was last raised in 2009
it's lost 17 percent of its value this
means that compared to 2009 minimum wage
workers have lost
3
950
every year so that's why a higher
minimum wage would boost economic growth
70 percent of the economy depends on
consumer spending so more money in
people's pockets means they can spend
more on the goods and services that keep
the economy going oh and raising the
minimum wage would reduce the amount of
money taxpayers spend on public
assistance that families need because
their breadwinners don't make enough to
live on
it's estimated that nearly half of
federal minimum wage workers families
are enrolled in at least one safety net
program costing the public 107 billion
dollars every year that's right our tax
dollars are subsidizing corporations
that don't pay a living wage
myth number four
most minimum wage workers are teenagers
making some extra money on the side they
don't need a wage increase
more rubbish
well this might have been the case in
1968 it certainly is not now
today
only one in 10 workers who would benefit
from a 15 minimum wage increase is a
teenager more than half of them are
between the ages of 25 and 54. more than
half of them work full-time and over a
quarter have children today's minimum
wage hurts people who are in their prime
earning years preventing them from
building wealth and establishing
financial security raising the minimum
wage would also help reduce racial and
gender pay disparities
minimum wage increases in expansions in
the late 1960s reduced the income gap
between black and white workers raising
the wage would have a similar effect
today because black workers hispanic
workers and women comprise a large
portion of today's low-wage workers
in sum
raising the minimum wage is good for
workers good for businesses and good for
the economy
in addition to all this raising the
minimum wage is the morally correct
thing to do it ought to lift working
people out of poverty not keep them in
it we're the richest country in the
world
home to the richest people on the planet
we can and we must treat our workers
with the dignity and respect they
deserve
that starts
with paying them a living wage
[Music]
[Music]
you